[Music]
love in lockdown
pam tells the daily mail she fell in
love with her bodyguard dan hayhurst
during quarantine and ended up tying the
knot during the holidays
in an intimate ceremony with no family
or friends
pam's rep tells et canada quote pamela
and dan's secret fairy tale wedding took
place christmas eve on her oceanfront
property
deep in the rainforest of vancouver
island first nations is dear to their
hearts
and the bride and groom were honored to
include a cedar blessing by the
co-salish band
pam reportedly met her new husband who
is also a builder from her hometown
at the beginning of the pandemic and the
pair have been inseparable
ever since she tells the daily mail
quote i'm exactly where i need to be
in the arms of a man who truly loves me
a friend of pam's
also tells the outlet quote pamela fell
in love with the boy next door
this is who she would have ended up with
if she never left vancouver island
i hear some good news you found love in
2020
that sounds such like it almost sounds
like a punchline but um
yeah i laverne is in love again
it feels amazing and today on ellen
laverne cox opens up about her lockdown
love
he's a really great guy and i didn't
expect it i thought he was just going to
be this
hot dude i was going to be hanging out
with and then it just kind of happened
wow congratulations can i can i ask how
long it's been going on
we've been hanging out for six months
and we went really slowly
so like the word love just sort of
happened like around
november december and exciting news for
marie kondo who's expecting
baby number three the organizational
expert and netflix star took to
instagram yesterday
showing off her baby bump writing
another bundle of joy
on the way